[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers in
allen guten Abend es sind Geschichten
die Herzen zerreißen zwei Dutzend Kinder
aus dem türkischen Nordteil von Zypern
auf Schulausflug zu einem
Volleyballturnier in der Türkei wo mal
ihr Hotel Stand ist jetzt eine einzige
Trümmerwüste das Wrack des Reisebusses
der sie herbrachte ist noch zu erkennen
seit Tagen rufen Helfer die Namen der
Kinder in einen furchteinflößenden Berg
aus Beton und Stahlstangen in der
Hoffnung dass jemand antwortet
aber es bleibt still überall im
Erdbebengebiet gibt es dieses Szenen die
Zahl der Toten in der Türkei und Syrien
ist auf mehr als 25.000 gestiegen Anne
Brühl ist in Adana
es ist eine riesige Lücke mitten in
Adana hier hat mal ein 13-stöckiges
Wohnhaus gestanden an der Absperrung
treffen wir neberhard pertschin die im
Nachbarhaus gewohnt hat
ich kann mich nicht darüber freuen dass
ich hier leben das meinem Apartment
rausgekommen bin das Gebäude hier hat
unseren Balkon mitgerissen als es
einstürzte wir leben noch aber sie alle
sind gestorben alle gestorben das waren
doch alles Nachbarn wir haben uns jeden
Tag gegrüßt
die Überwachungskameras eines
angrenzenden Wohnhauses hat den Moment
in dem es passierte aufgezeichnet
so einen Krach habe ich noch nie gehört
danach dann der Einsturz von diesem
Gebäude wie eine Bombe die Schreie der
Menschen mir geht es psychisch nicht gut
viele hier sind schockiert wie schnell
die Toten geborgen die Trümmer beseitigt
wurden
ein Ingenieur der Stadtverwaltung ist
gekommen spricht mit den Nachbarn ihre
Häuser sind einsturzgefährdet eigentlich
darf niemand sie mehr betreten viele
versuchen aber trotzdem kurz noch das
Nötigste aus ihren Wohnungen zu holen
auch ne hat war schon oben
ich bin in meiner Wohnung reingegangen
habe im Korridor alles gecheckt das sind
Schäden die man reparieren kann die
Reparatur kosten werden nicht hoch sein
in Adana geht es jetzt vor allem um die
Überlebenden in einem Basar in der
Innenstadt hat der türkische
Katastrophenschutz Zelte aufgebaut für
die die nicht mehr zurück dürfen in ihre
Häuser Ismael Sarac ist mit Frau und
drei kleinen Kindern seit Montag hier
zeigt uns sein Zelt
weil es nachts so kalt wird haben wir
mehrere Decken jeder hat drei bis vier
Decken
kam sein Sohn ist gestern fünf geworden
stolz zeigt er uns den Spider-Man Pulli
den er von den Helfern hier geschenkt
bekommen hat
Sicherheit ist auch in Adana ein Thema
alles in Ordnung sagt uns der
polizeischiff im Interview
als Polizei haben bei allen
eingestürzten Häusern
Sicherheitsmaßnahmen getroffen wir haben
denjenigen die bei Rettungsaktionen
dabei waren geholfen wir treffen auch
Maßnahmen gegen Diebstahl
während der mit uns spricht haben seine
Kollegen auf der Straße gerade einen
Plünderer erwischt
eine guten Abend was kannst du uns zur
Sicherheitslage sagen sind das
Verbrecher die diese Situation jetzt
ausnutzen oder einfach verzweifelte
Menschen die zu allem bereit sind
die Verzweiflung überwiegt hier wenn wir
zum Drehen unterwegs sind dann begegnen
wir eigentlich immer hochtraumatisierten
Menschen Überlebenden andere die noch
Familienangehörige oder Freunde unter
den Truman haben und wenn die dann hören
dass auch nach all den Tagen noch
Menschen gerettet werden gleichzeitig
aber sehen wie bei Ihnen zu Hause Bagger
und schweres Gerät schon alles platt
macht dann kippt die Situation oft das
wird aggressiv die Stimmung ist dann
aufgeheizt oder Menschen den
lebenswichtige Medikamente fehlen auf
der anderen Seite gibt es natürlich auch
solche die die Situation ausnutzen das
werden ja auch zum Beispiel
Elektrogeschäfte geplündert was auffällt
hier auf den Straßen ist die
Polizeipräsenz in den letzten Tagen
extrem viel größer geworden auch sehr
viel Militär ist unterwegs in den zehn
Erdbeben Provinzen gilt ja der
Ausnahmezustand die Türkei will ganz
offensichtlich Stärke zeigen eine Brühe
für uns in Andernach eine vielen Dank
und auch heute an dieser Stelle der
Hinweis für Sie wenn Sie spenden wollen
dass Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
hat folgendes Konto
de65100
400-600-100 400 das Stichwort lautet ZDF
Erdbeben Türkei Syrien und mehr
informationen auch unter Spenden zdf.de
im Internet oder im ZDF Text auf Seite
in Frankreich waren heute wieder
hunderttausende Menschen auf den Straßen
quer durchs Land Paris Nizza Toulouse
sie wollen ihren Präsidenten klar machen
was sie von dessen planen für eine
Rentenreform halten nämlich nichts heute
waren auch auffallend viele junge
Menschen dabei für die die Rente noch
weit weg ist wenn es nach Emmanuel
macron geht künftig noch weiter weg
zumindest auf den ersten Blick hat
Frankreich aktuell eines der
großzügigsten Rentensysteme weltweit mit
mehr dazu
ihr Protest ist wieder massiv macron
führt die Wut mit seinem Plan das
Renteneintrittsalter von 62 auf 64 Jahre
anzuheben Sabrina wennali notfallärztin
in Paris ist mit Mann und Kind gekommen
wie viele hier fühlen Sie sich ungehört
von einer wunderbaren Elite
fremdbestimmt
noch unser Schuldirektor er steht im
Dienst der Franzosen er darf nicht
einfach so über unser Leben entscheiden
und erst recht nicht wenn er damit nur
dem Finanzmarkt einen Gefallen tun will
und so spiegelt der Aufruhr gegen die
Reform längst einen anderen größeren
Konflikt die Verteilungskämpfe im Land
haben sich verschärft
viele meiner Kolleginnen haben
Rückenprobleme sind der schöpft und die
Regierung verlangt nur von uns Arbeitern
länger zu schuften aber nie von den
Aktionären dass sie sich an den Kosten
beteiligen
auch im Parlament der Assam Lena
national Proteste die Opposition hat
etwa 20.000 Änderungsanträge eingebracht
gegen ein Gesetz mit dem die Regierung
das Rentensystem langfristig
gegenfinanzieren will angesichts des
demografischen Wandels sei die Reform
unumgänglich
Demographie
übrigens kein anderes Land in Europa
bleibt in dieser Frage untätig fast alle
haben das Renteneintrittsalter bereits
erhöht
den Verweis auf andere Länder lassen sie
in Frankreichs Protest Zügen nicht
gelten länger arbeiten empfinden sie als
längeres Leiden einen Einschnitt in die
einst erkämpfte Freiheit der frühen
Rente und so folgen 100000e dem Aufruf
zum erneuten Widerstand
wir wollten heute ein Zeichen setzen und
das ist uns gelungen überall in
Frankreich war die Beteiligung hoch sie
müssen uns jetzt zuhören
zudem drohen mehrere Gewerkschaften nun
mit einem Generalstreik am 7 März sollte
das Gesetz nicht zurückgezogen werden
der Druck steigt von Woche zu Woche
am 31 Dezember sollte Schluss sein mit
Kernkraftwerken in Deutschland die
letzten drei von ihnen laufen jetzt aber
doch weiter längstens bis zum 15 April
die Bundesregierung will so die
Energieversorgung sichern
Atomkraftgegner fürchten dass es danach
dennoch weitergehen könnte sie
protestieren heute in Landshut für ein
Ende sofort in der Nähe liegt das AKW
Isa 2
wo Deutschland mit seinem Atommüll hin
will ist derweil unklarer denn je und
selbst für ein Land das enorme
Verzögerungen bei staatlichen Planungen
ja irgendwie immer mit einplant ist das
Szenario haarsträubend die Suche nach
einem Endlager wird wohl bis Mitte des
Jahrhunderts dauern mindestens Oliver
deuka berichtet
das Milliardengrab Jahrzehnte lang galt
das Erkundungsbergwerk nahe des
niedersächsischen Örtchens Gorleben als
potentielles Endlager für
hochradioaktiven Müll doch seit
September 2020 ist dieser Salzstock
endgültig draußen Deutschland sucht ein
Endlager und tut sich schwer damit
naja die das Misstrauen ist natürlich da
dass wenn es schwierig wird bei der
Endlagersuche dass man auf alte Fehler
zurückfällt also Kriterien anzupassen an
das was man vorfindet inzwischen Lagern
deutschlandweit warten rund 1.900
Behälter mit hochstrahlendem Müll auf
die Endlagerung nach der Gorleben Pleite
Neuanfang weiße Landkarte ein
Standortauswahlgesetz regelt nun die
Endlagersuche wir haben ein Verfahren
was transparent nachvollziehbar
wissenschaftsbasiert ist und eben auch
fair gestaltet wird was aber noch nicht
passiert ist dass in der Gesellschaft
angekommen ist das ist nicht mehr darum
geht heldenhaft die Verhinderung zu
verfolgen sondern dass die wahren Helden
diejenigen sind die sich konsequent in
dem Suchen und Finden und sich dem
stellen des Problems dann auf entlang
wie ich machen ein Endlager in
Deutschland zu realisieren
im europäischen Ausland scheint man da
weiter zu sein Finnlands Endlager fast
fertig auch Frankreich hat sich
festgelegt dass teslabor Büren Nordosten
des Landes wird zum Endlager ausgebaut
und auch die Schweiz hat nahe der
deutschen Grenze eingeeigneten Standort
gefunden und Deutschland diesmal nur
keine Fehler machen ein guter Anspruch
der hat aber folgen wenn ideale auf
Realität treffen auf praktikabilitäten
auf Budget Bedarf ja dann muss man
sozusagen immer wieder austarieren wo
man wie man das Ideal die ideale am
besten erreichen kann und trotzdem
natürlich weiterkommt wenn man nur auf
der Seite der ideale bleibt dann naja
dann reicht es nie und dann schafft man
aber auch nichts
2031 so der Plan sollte der Standort des
deutschen Endlagers feststehen seit
neuestem heißt es es könnte sogar bis
2068 dauern das Problem wir haben hier
in Gollum ein Zwischenlager und die
Betriebszeit läuft 2034 aus es darf hier
keine einfache Verlängerung der
Zwischenlagerung geben diese
Zwischenlager sind für 40 Jahre
genehmigt seitdem beschlossenen Ausstieg
aus der Kernenergie ist das Thema für
viele Menschen beendet einhergehend ist
das gesellschaftspolitische Interesse an
einem Endlager verloren gegangen das
Problem aussitzen wie so oft schwierig
eine Million Jahre strahlt hochadjektive
Atommüll
das Thema bleibt uns erhalten das kann
man jetzt schon vorhersehen so und wir
beginnen jetzt den Nachrichtenüberblick
mit einem Thema das uns aktuell jeden
Abend beschäftigt an dieser Stelle und
mit Johanna ja ganz genau über Kanada
soll offenbar ein unbekanntes Flugobjekt
in großer Höhe entdeckt worden sein
möglicherweise ein weiterer Balance das
teilte vor wenigen Minuten ein
gemeinsames
luftverteidigungskommando Kanadas und
der USA mit drei dieser Objekte waren in
den vergangenen Tagen über Nord und
Südamerika entdeckt worden bei einem
davon soll es sich um einen chinesischen
spionageballon gehandelt haben
vor rund fünf Monaten begannen in Iran
die landesweiten regimekritischen
Proteste heute aber versammelten sich
Zehntausende Anhänger der Regierung auf
den Straßen und den Jahrestag der
islamischen Revolution zu feiern die
Kundgebungen wie hier in Teheran wurden
vom Regime selbst organisiert Präsident
reisin nutzte den Anlass und behauptete
die Proteste sein gescheitert zudem
sprach er von einem vom Ausland
gesteuerten Verschwörungen
Land soll ein israelischer Siedler einen
Palästinenser durch einen Schuss in den
Kopf getötet haben das teilten
palästinensische Behörden mit das
israelische militärsprach von
Konfrontationen zwischen Israelis und
Palästinensern die israelische Polizei
leitete Ermittlungen ein unterdessen
wurde bekannt dass die Zahl der Toten
nach dem gestrigen Anschlag eines
Palästinensers in Ost Jerusalem auf drei
gestiegen ist ein achtjähriger Junge
erlag seinen schweren Verletzungen
im Rahmen der Ermittlungen zur
Korruptionsaffäre im EU-Parlament ist
heute Haftbefehl gegen einen weiteren
Abgeordneten erlassen worden dem
Sozialdemokraten Markt tarabella werden
laut Staatsanwaltschaft unter anderem
Korruption und Geldwäsche vorgeworfen
der belgia war gestern festgenommen
worden genauso wie der italienische
Abgeordnete Andrea kozolino Hintergrund
des Korruptions Skandals ist die
mutmaßliche Bestechung von
EU-Abgeordneten durch Katha und Marokko
Hans Modrow hat in seinem langen Leben
als Abgeordneter drei sehr
unterschiedliche Parlamente erlebt
zuletzt das Europaparlament davor den
Bundestag davor mehr als 30 Jahre lang
die DDR Volkskammer in der abgenickt
wurde was die SED Machthaber entschieden
auch zu ihnen hat Modrow gehört
seiner Partei von der SED über die PDS
bis zur Linken galt er als überzeugter
Sozialist einer allerdings der etwa den
Bau der Berliner Mauer auch im Rückblick
für gerechtfertigt hielt Hans Modrow ist
vergangene Nacht gestorben er wurde 95
Jahre alt Henriette de Maizière er
diente ein Leben lang seiner Partei von
der SED über PDS bis hin zur Linken
hansmoto
wer sich ein böse dass man überhaupt und
politisch leben kann der irrt sich der
gelernte maschinenbauschlosser machte
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg in der neu
gegründeten DDR schnell Karriere
studierte in der Sowjetunion
Wirtschaftswissenschaften wehnte sich
auf der richtigen Seite wir waren schon
der Überzeugung das bessere Deutschland
entsteht im Osten und von dort wird
einmal das Verein der Deutschland
entstehen im Wende Herbst 1989 wurde
Hans Mode für viele zum Hoffnungsträger
ging auf Bürgerrechtler zu fünf Monate
lang stand der an der Spitze des DDR
Ministerrat die Regierung der DDR ist
bereit die Zusammenarbeit mit der BRD
umfassend auszubauen umstritten in das
blieb modros Rolle bei einem
Polizeieinsatz im Oktober 1989 in
Dresden auch wegen des Vorwurfs der
Wahlfälschung wurde er nach der Wende
verurteilt die schnelle deutsche Einheit
sah er stets kritisch Hans Modrow blieb
seinem sozialistischen Weltbild bis zum
Schluss treu und ein durch und durch
politischer Mensch
und wie jeden Samstag jetzt noch der
Blick auf die Lottozahlen die lauten 9
11 12 19 28 30 Superzahl 3 alle Angaben
wie immer ohne Gewähr
und so wird das Wetter in den kommenden
Tagen morgen im Südwesten und am
Alpenrand länger sonnig sonst oft trübe
und nur weniger Auflockerungen
vereinzelt auch etwas Sprühregen 4 bis
11 Grad in der neuen Woche ruhiges
Wetter mit einer Mischung aus
sonnewolken und teilszähmen Nebel
Höchstwerte zwischen 4 und 12 Grad
so und wir sagen danke dass Sie bei uns
waren ja und die nächsten Nachrichten
gibt es gegen 0:25 Uhr heute Express mit
Antoine morgen Berlin Wahl auch bei uns
ab 21:45
[Musik]